So far, we've spoken about all of the wonderful benefits that sleep provides,...
...but how much sleep should we actually be getting?
For the average adult, the current recommendation...
...is somewhere between seven to nine hours of sleep a night.
And what we've been finding from large-scale epidemiological studies...
...is that, using that reference point of seven to nine hours,...
...once you start to drop below that, your mortality risk actually starts to increase.
In fact, the Center for Disease Control in the United States, or the CDC,...
...they stipulate a minimum of seven hours of sleep a night for the average adult.
In other words, the shorter your sleep, the shorter your life.
But it turns out that it's not quite a linear relationship as you would expect.
It's not as though the more and more that you sleep,...
...the lower and lower your mortality risk is.
In fact, something strange happens.
Once you get past nine hours, you actually start to see a rise back up in mortality risk,...
...which seems rather strange and peculiar.